With Hitman Agent 47 out now, let's take a
look at 5 things you probably didn't know
about the movie based on the hit video game
series.
Stunt and Fight Co-ordinators Jonathan Eusebio
and Jon Valera created contrasting fight styles
for Agent 47, who's played by Rupert Friend,
and John Smith, who's played by Zachary Quinto.
They based John Smith's technique on traditional
Japanese karate and some kickboxing, and gave
him a haymaker-punching style.
And to give 47 his own distinct style, they
trained Friend in Malaysian Silat and Filipino
martial arts.
As part of his 6 months of training, Friend
also learned boxing, some Judo and Kung-fu,
and Krav maga which is a form of self-defence
system developed by the Israeli military.
Friend also did intensive training with the
movie's armaments team to make sure he was
comfortable with Agent 47's signature weapon,
the Silverballers pistols.
He even took them home with him to practise,
and, according to the actor, by the end of
his training, he could take the gun apart
and put it back together again with his eyes
closed.
However, Friend still managed to injure himself
on set when he fired his gun into the ground
by accident and a blank cartridge bounced
up and hit him in the head!
Despite being hurt, Friend kept filming and
the take actually made it into the final movie!
But that's not the first time the actor's
got caught out by a gun on set.
When he was filming Homeland, a stray bullet
from someone else's gun accidentally hit Friend
in the neck!
Speaking of Homeland, while filming Hitman
Agent 47, Hannah Ware, who plays Katia van
Dees in the movie, was pretty persistent in
trying to prise spoilers about Homeland out
of Rupert Friend, who plays CIA Agent Peter
Quinn on the hit TV show.
But Friend managed to keep quiet about the
show's future twists and instead had fun teasing
his curious co-star during the shoot!
Rupert Friend made a deliberate decision not
to watch the first movie adapted from the
Hitman video games which was released in 2007.
Friend avoided the movie which starred Timothy
Olyphant as he didn't want to be influenced
by someone else's interpretation of his character,
Agent 47.
Instead, he relied on the video games, and
was particularly influenced by what he describes
as the "deadly graceful" way Agent 47 moves
in the 2012 instalment, Absolution.
After experiencing the games, Friend also
felt strongly that the movie should put more
emphasis on the elements of stealth, cunning
and disguise, and worked with the stunt team
to include 47's trademark garrotte, or fibre
wire.
To get Agent 47's signature look right, the
movie's costume designer visited many design
houses in New York, and also in Germany, where
part of the film was shot.
But in the end, to get the classic, well-cut
outfit she wanted, she hired a tailor from
Madrid who flew out to the film's set to create
the suit from scratch.
Ten black suits, 10 white shirts, and 10 red
ties were custom-made from finely woven cotton
for the shoot.
Rupert Friend said that when he put them on,
he "felt like an assassin who's paid millions
to do his job."
Now, let me know in the comments below, what
other video games would you like to see on
the big screen?
And what's your favourite video game movie
& why?
My next movie review is going to be on the
horror sequel Sinister 2.
And if you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for more things you didn't know, as well as
movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!